[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
et faut-il généraliser le service
national universel
la mise en place d'un service national
universel le SNU avait pour objectif de
favoriser la mixité sociale mais surtout
d'enseigner aux jeunes les enjeux de la
Défense et de les inciter à l'engagement
associatif 4 années après le début de
l'expérimentation 9 jeunes volontaires
sur 10 se disent satisfaits du séjour de
cohésion qui est la première phase du
SNU en 2022 ils étaient 32 400 jeunes à
y participer en 2023 l'objectif fixé par
le gouvernement et de porter ce nombre à
pourtant alors que la généralisation du
SNU est envisagée de nombreux obstacles
se dressent devant ce projet c'est ce
que souligne Eric janssanettas
rapporteur spécial de la mission sport
jeunesse et vie associative dans le
rapport de contrôle budgétaire sur le
SNU qu'il a présenté à la commission des
finances tout d'abord le rapporteur fait
remarquer que la représentativité
sociale du séjour de cohésion peut être
améliorée il y a en effet une
sur-représentation des jeunes
participants dont l'un des parents
travaillent dans les corps en uniforme
33% en 2022 contre 2% dans la population
générale
concernant la généralisation du s&u deux
scénarios sont envisagés un premier
consiste à généraliser le SMU hors du
temps scolaire le second sur le temps
scolaire
or cela supposerait une articulation
entre l'administration du SNU et
l'éducation nationale qui reste
entièrement à construire
quel que soit le scénario retenu la
généralisation du SMUR rencontre de
difficultés majeures et tendre
l'expérimentation exigerait de recruter
entre 15000 et 50 000 encadrants selon
le scénario retenu ce qui impliquerait
de créer une véritable filière du SNU
qui prendrait plusieurs années à être
opérationnel et la difficulté de trouver
des sites d'hébergement déjà constaté
durant l'expérimentation risque de
conduire à des surcoûts importants la
logistique requise pour accueillir
l'ensemble d'une classe d'âge soit 840
000 jeunes supposerait la création d'une
véritable administration du service
national universel
un tel dispositif généralisé
entraînerait semblablement un coût
annuel du SNU supérieur à 2 milliards
d'euros évalue le rapporteur spécial
dans ces conditions la commission des
finances recommande de suspendre le
projet de généralisation du séjour de
cohésion d'ailleurs selon Eric
janssanettas c'est le dispositif
lui-même qui devrait faire l'objet d'une
nouvelle réflexion pour être orienté en
direction de l'engagement civique or à
cet égard la seconde phase du dispositif
actuel la mission d'intérêt général
n'est pas satisfaisante les structures
d'accueil peuvent être réticentes à
accueillir des jeunes pour dédurer
inférieures à plusieurs mois de plus il
peut s'avérer difficile pour des jeunes
de trouver une mission proche de chez
eux
le rapporteur recommande donc la
suppression de la mission d'intérêt
général au profit de l'engagement
volontaire sur plusieurs mois plus
globalement le projet de généralisation
du séjour de cohésion soulève des
questions importantes relatives aux
libertés individuelles des jeunes et à
la façon dont la nation reconnaît leur
engagement enfin la Commission souhaite
avoir la garantie de la part du
gouvernement que le Parlement puisse se
prononcer sur le service national
universel
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]